I've orgasmed I've orgasmed I've
orgasmed I've orgasmed I've orgasmed
I've orgasmed
so I'll start with kind of like my ish I
kind of like stayed away from sex for a
while but then I went to college had
that college experience it's kind of
progressed a lot from there was it your
first organism in general or with
someone else with someone else for me
personally I was never really concerned
with like dating a relationship and then
I met this guy in class and our first
hookup like did not go as planned as I
feel like it never did yeah then I like
came out to California and I started
like dating and I think that's when like
I had my first orgasm I feel like there
were times where like you fake it
because like you know you might love him
or you might not love him it's like let
me just do what I can in this moment
there was something just sus about her
she's too sweet to be able to like say
her piece in bed I didn't finish because
of a partner until I realized I was
lesbian so I was just like with a guy
after guy after guy and I was like why
isn't this working like something just
not clicking and I definitely thought it
was like something about me or my body
like I thought I was being difficult and
then I was like oh it's not a me thing
like at all yeah four years ago was when
I got sexually active and my first time
also was terrible it was at this
situationship wait so when did you have
your first orgasm with a partner it
would be four years ago when I was in
that situationship oh like even though
it was like yeah
but we still yeah oh okay okay okay yeah
you think shoot I wish I stopped at you
you wish you could have lived okay I
didn't have my first orgasm with a
partner till I was like 21. I feel like
that goes into a lot of sex education
and being taught like sex is for like
babies and not to achieve orgasm but it
happened yeah it keeps happening I would
say the first time I actually orgasm
with a partner I was 21. it was just
kind of funny because I didn't think I
was going to lose it until I like got
married I'm like third generation like
hyper religious family so Church girls
thank you
[Music]
she was like giving me like young
innocent vibes
just off of like initial stories I felt
like hers was the most vague
something she said threw off my guitar
I'm usually really good at detecting
women who go both ways so that was a
surprise
wow really oh bye Mia bye just based off
of the first initial take it's kind of
hard to relate to my story where it
seems very like Fantastical or weird
um so it kind of makes sense I have a
question what was your best sexual
experience
sexual experience or best orgasm
I would say I I like seeing like
experience do you want to share first
sure I would say actually recently I
went for my friend's birthday and we
went out to a bar that was very first
time going home with somebody oh and I
think that was my favorite for sure just
because the spontaneity of it and the
guy was older so he just really knew
what he was like
I feel like mine isn't the like best one
to go off of but it was the best
experience for me
um I was on my period maybe TMI I don't
know but there was just something about
her I was like I don't care you don't
care and then it just happened and I was
like that's hot ugly face every day yeah
guys right there like uh like like we
need to stop so I've had multiple
experiences years back with older men
like mid 30s to 40s there was one
experience it was just like it wasn't
planned like it was just in the moment
and like he just knew what he was doing
and it's like the like you know like
grabbing me
yes I've been I've been in theater
I feel convincing
I think for me was actually like a guy
that I just met in college and me and my
friends always make the joke like if
they ask me where I'm going like oh I'm
gonna go see rocket ship because that's
what I called him like that's but I felt
like in that moment when you've never
had an orgasm and it happens I just feel
like it's like stars just like that's
what it felt like to me so for me this
threesome I had with the well-known guy
and his girlfriend he had like a
playlist like Drake and
like it was just you know it's a lot of
like sexual tension in one space is
that's like the main part of it I feel
like is not just like specifically the
sex it's the experience of it exactly
because me specifically like I'm not
gonna come like just from like well
that's what I was gonna say is like it I
wouldn't say it was like the best sex of
my life but when I think like sexual
experience that's the first one because
it was such a mood and of course like
since I'm like the guest star I'm like
extra paid attention too yeah so I was
like doing things I was on like my head
doing like a handstand I love it it was
crazy so with that in mind like what
does an orgasm actually feel like to you
because I said it feels like a rocket
shed like a spaceship honestly like for
me your body like tenses up how I it
kind of feels like melting sometimes but
then sometimes like if you change the
momentum and it's slow it feels like
butterflies and Bub you know what I mean
I feel like every orgasm to me is like
definitely different yeah one way of
putting it is like I feel like I'm gonna
pee like I have to focus like I have to
like make it happen I otherwise like if
I stop thinking about it then it's not
then it doesn't I'm the same I've heard
some people like say that who aren't
like really experienced sexually so I
was like maybe she's just trying to go
off like Internet Resources I feel like
I honestly blank out
[Laughter]
is white hot but I just blank out I feel
like it's just like one of the few times
I can really like let go and just be
present because my brain is just always
going on so it depends if it's the first
organ because I have this thing where
like once I come I can like keep coming
like 10 times like in a row I've had
orgasms where it's just like yours where
it's like I really had to like
concentrate to get there and then others
where I'm like you know I'm like oh my
God
moment
[Music]
her recollection of her orgasm it felt
very like by the book
I was like it's Sarah Jada but then Jada
was like oh I call my guy Rocket Man you
only give nicknames to some good
no no
I think I said something about it taking
so long for me to get there with a
partner and then when I said church girl
I was like maybe I shouldn't have said
that if you think the mole is still in
the box and you'd wish to play the game
please raise your hand at this time
wait I have a question when did it come
to the understanding or if you always
had it where an orgasm is about both
people I would say in college because I
like you I wasn't really into it
sexually that's when I was interested in
learning about other people especially
you know what I mean yeah after I left
my four-year relationship he had told me
like oh no one's ever gonna love you
like no one's ever going to want to have
sex with you again like literally those
words and every partner after that I've
been like focused on that like it's
never been about me it's always been
about how can I please them I was
thinking okay well maybe she switched
tactics and that's what really brings
her pleasure is bringing other people
pleasure I was never really a sexual
person anyway like I had the purity ring
I was saving myself for marriage my
answer is around church I was raised
like super Catholic and so for me it
didn't even really conceive in my head
that like oh this is for women too
because everything is so like giving
serving for the man cooking cleaning for
the man having a household for the man I
didn't even literally start like thing
thinking like I want to come too until I
was like 21 and that was like our
cultural influences and women talking
about sex and being more open it's for
both people it's not just like me giving
all to you because I'm like what am I
here for I have a question so how did
you feel the first time someone was able
to get you there like especially because
it sounds like a lot of us had religious
backgrounds like because I know the
first time I felt it it took me a second
to feel okay yeah and like I remember
during the whole process just feeling
like I was being watched like I have a
lot of like deceased loved ones too so
like just feeling like they were
watching me am I doing something bad wow
yeah
it is
mentally what you go through then later
on it's like shoot they can watch what
they watch
one of the things was the white shirt I
don't know when I think of why I think
of Purity she also said something about
how she wanted to save herself for
marriage she had a purity ring so I'm
like if you add all those things
together
felt like she was kind of like talking a
little too much and trying to explain
her story to where we believed it
foreign
I felt like I was very authentic with my
story I think I talked a little more
about my past experience with my
Christianity plus the white shirt I
think they kind of they kind of went for
that too if the lights turn green that
means that you have all voted them all
out and you win if the lights turn red
that means the mole is still in the box
and you all lose and three
two
[Applause]
oh no will the mole please step forward
in three
two
one
[Music]
oh not you I like to think I had
intuition when the light turned red and
there was three of us I was like I knew
it was Jada and
I have never come from someone else
um giving that to me I enjoy sex all the
time
um I just nobody has really taken the
time to learn how to make me come I
guess so I love talking about sex
because I think that there's this
narrative that everybody should be able
to come just you know and I don't and I
still have fun and I still learn a lot
about myself wow you got us good
I was nervous it never would I guess my
biggest goals today was to use my
authentic experiences without inherently
lying probably should have paid more
attention to her yeah that's a woman
that gets what she wants and she did
dang it
[Applause]
[Music]
I wanted to come here today to show that
sex is just so different for everybody
and you just have to find your way and
you find your flow and just because you
have an orgasm doesn't mean that you
don't have good sex I just hope everyone
can get inspired by this episode to ask
for their wants and needs during sex and
hopefully you come and you come hard